judge katanji jackson has officially
been confirmed to the supreme court
president biden is pleased probably
because jackson's confirmation is the
first political win of his entire
administration but even so
biden is angry that the confirmation
didn't go even easier i knew it wouldn't
be easy
but i knew the person i nominated will
be put through a painful and difficult
confirmation process
but i have to tell you
what judge jackson was put through
was well beyond that
there was verbal abuse the anger
the constant interruptions
the most vile baseless assertions and
accusations
in the face of it all
judge jackson showed the incredible
character and integrity she possesses
the most vile baseless assertions and
accusations
the most vile faceless assertions and
accusations does joe biden not remember
four years ago well actually probably he
does not remember four years ago but
does everyone else not remember four
years ago when during brett kavanaugh's
confirmation hearings the democrats
accused him a squeaky clean milktoast
federal judge of attempted rape
i believed he was going to rape me
i tried to yell for help
when i did brett put his hand over my
mouth to stop me from yelling
this is what terrified me the most and
has had the most lasting impact on my
life
it was hard for me to breathe
and i thought that brett was
accidentally going to kill me
dr ford
with what degree of certainty do you
believe brett kavanaugh assaulted you
100
what is the strongest memory you have
indelible in the hippocampus is the
laughter
the la the uproarious laughter between
the two
and they're
having fun
at my expense was there ever a time when
you drank so much that you couldn't
remember what happened or part of what
happened the night before i
no in your yearbook
you talked about
drinking
and sexual exploits did you not
indelible in the hippocampus
is the laughter that i engaged in at
this preposterous circus there was no
evidence for any of these claims
none whatsoever that woman christine
ford changed almost all of the crucial
details of her story multiple times she
was caught in multiple lies the other
people said to have been at this party
from hell at the time said they had no
idea what this woman was talking about
even ford's best friend also said to
have been there contradicted ford's
story but that didn't stop democrats
from continuing to smear brett kavanaugh
without any evidence as a rapist and
then even going further to accuse him of
gang rape
a third woman is now leveling damaging
accusations against supreme court
nominee brett kavanaugh her name is
julie swetnick and she's represented by
attorney michael avenatti of stormy
daniels fame swetnick claims that
kavanaugh was present while she herself
was being gang raped at a house party in
the 1980s
the detail
includes and what is included in
kavanaugh's sworn affidavit excuse me in
avenetti's sworn affidavit that julie
swetnick gave
in it she says in approximately 1982 i
became the victim of one of these gang
or train rapes where michael judge mark
judge and brett kavanaugh were present
shortly after the incident i shared what
had transpired with at least two other
people during the incident i was
incapacitated without my consent unable
to fight off the boys raping me i
believe i was drugged using quaaludes or
something similar placed in what i was
drinking
she also says quote i also witnessed
efforts by mark judge brett kavanaugh
and others to cause girls to become
inebriated and disoriented so they could
then be gang raped
gang raped
they said that brett kavanaugh was a
gang rapist now this woman julie
swetnick was discredited almost
immediately even the democrats quickly
moved on from her nonsense her felon
lawyer who is previously best known for
defrauding a porn star is currently in
prison for extortion and wire fraud but
to this day to this day democrats
continue to smear brett kavanaugh as
some sort of rapist with these vague
accusations based on absolutely nothing
this after the democrats led by joe
biden baselessly smeared clarence thomas
as a sexual predator that after the
democrats again led by joe biden because
he's been in politics for that long
inaugurated this whole era of supreme
court confirmation smears during the
nomination of robert bork it created a
new verb borking which is when you smear
a candidate for the court now
joe biden has the audacity to complain
about vile baseless accusations against
catanji jackson
which consisted entirely
of quoting her own record and asking her
basic questions about the world
and i'll confess judge jackson as look
as i listen to your testimony i believe
you are someone who is compassionate i
believe you care for children obviously
your children and other children
but i also see a record
of activism and advocacy as it concerns
sexual predators
that stems back decades and that is
concerning he said to him this is a
truly difficult situation
i appreciate that your family's in the
audience i feel so sorry for them
and for you
and for the anguish this has caused all
of you
i feel terrible about the collateral
consequences of this
conviction
and then you're going to say sex
offenders are truly shunned in our
society
i'm just trying to figure out judge
is he the victim here or the victim's
the victims
prosecutors you've spoken a lot today
about criminal senate saying about the
theory of sentencing you've written
about a lot about in your record it is a
very simple question
is someone more likely or less likely to
commit crime if they're certain more
certain that they're going to be caught
convicted and sentenced
can you provide a definition for the
word woman
can i provide a definition no yeah
i can't
you can't
you can't
you can't the entire process was just
quoting her own record almost entirely
in her own words quoting her own
sentencing record and then asking simple
questions like what is a woman and this
woman maybe she's a woman maybe she's
not i don't know either way she couldn't
answer
the only vile and baseless accusations
in the entire jackson confirmation
process have been the ones that biden
and the democrats have hurled against
the republicans about the process in
other words business as usual i'm
michael knowles it's the michael knowles
show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment on friday is from william c who
says there's nothing i want more now
than to have ashton kutcher come out and
inform us all that we've been punked i'm
with you i and now with the
proliferation of deep fakes and
photoshop becoming very advanced when i
see something about joe biden in the
white house
my first instinct is to say this isn't
real this can't possibly be real this is
so
pathetic there's no way and then i look
into it and it turns out that it is real
when you want to see things clearly when
you want to shed a little light for
instance on your home i would recommend
you check out hunter douglas right now
go to hunterdouglas.com
knowles i did not realize this
before i got my house in nashville and
really started to take a little more
care into the way i was living to you
know no longer living on a pile of
magazines on the floor but actually
taking care about the beauty of my home
windows and window treatments
i think they might be the single most
important thing in your home because it
determines how the light comes in it it
totally shapes how you live in your home
hunter douglas has incredible designs
gorgeous fabrics control systems so
advanced they can be scheduled to
automatically adjust to their optimal
position throughout the day as the sun
moves through the sky it's incredible
the shades diffuse the harsh sunlight
they cast this beautiful glow across the
room it's phenomenal take my word for it
right now go to hunter douglas make your
home beautiful that's hunterdouglas.com
slash knowles head over there today get
your free style get smarter design guide
with fresh takes creative ideas and
smart solutions for dressing your
windows hunterdouglas.com
knowles for your free design guide there
was a clip going around friday afternoon
i said this cannot be real
i do not believe it
even joe biden as senile and far gone as
he is there's no way this is real joe
biden during
the katanji jackson confirmation process
right now she's going to be on the court
he tried to sum up america
in one word tell me if you can figure
out what that word is
america is a nation that can be defined
in a single word
i was going to put him a
foot
excuse me in the foothills of the
himalayas with xi jinping
traveling with him
unless we traveled 17 000 miles when i
was vice president i don't know that for
a fact
one word that sums up america is ash
with me i was writing in the foothills
of the himalayas
you know i think was it benjamin
franklin who said that or it might have
been george washington who said america
if i had to sum up america my fellow
countrymen in one word it would be
and i couldn't have meant
is that it no it it's sad because
obviously
that the word is nonsense but also even
if he hadn't
had a
spark go off in his brain so that he
just stammered for uh three minutes
even if that hadn't happened he said i'm
going to sum up america in one word and
then proceeded to talk about a trip he
had to the himalayas with xi jinping
that was not in one word and was
completely unrelated to what he was
talking about
the guy is just not i didn't believe it
when i saw it i said there's no way this
is real
but it is real it is real he
he biden at this point
seems almost ancillary to the operation
of the white house this is why when
barack obama showed back up no one
wanted to talk to joe biden
people want to talk to the person with
the power okay people want to be around
the person with the influence
and no one is paying any attention to
joe biden you can even see katanji
jackson in the background there oh gosh
why
so i've worked my whole career for this
and now this
this guy is just stammering idiotically
some people though are
a slightly more articulate than joe
biden cory booker thanking god for
sending us katanji jackson
just finished the vote uh
katanji brown jackson has now been
confirmed by the senate to be a justice
on the supreme court
and i think there are a lot of people
who can appreciate this that
there is a lot of
hurt in this world there's a lot of
private pain and
personal
injury and
we live in a nation with
acres of ground that's been watered with
tears and
sadness but today is
a mountain of joy today is a day for
celebration today i rejoice
i
i cry tears of joy
and i just want to thank god and thank
this extraordinary woman for persevering
through all of life's challenges for
overcoming
all of life's obstacles and now rising
and knowing as when i talk to her she
knows that we
as a nation rise
rise with her
we rise we rise with her i would like to
implement the cory booker don't be a
weirdo for five minutes challenge i'm
willing to put a million dollars on the
line for this i'll borrow money if i
have to
it's the cory booker stop being a total
weirdo for five minutes challenge i'm
willing to wager that money because it's
impossible
it can't happen we're better we're
rising i rejoice rejoice for what
rejoice for what the the answer for the
left is that they're just happy that
she's black and that she's a woman
that's all this nomination has ever been
about don't take my word for it that's
what joe biden said joe biden said i am
going to nominate a black woman that's
all i care about and so i'm gonna pick
one basically throw a dart at a wall oh
katanji jackson okay it's her she's the
one and that's all anyone cares about
she's obviously
not the smartest person ever put on the
court she doesn't know what a woman is
she's by far the most radical i guess
that's something that the democrats are
excited about as well she doesn't like
america she's endorsed the completely
dishonest 1619 project which says
america is intrinsically evil and the
revolution was fought to protect slavery
she supports critical race theory she
lauds the founders of critical race
theory
critical race theory which holds that
america is intrinsically rotten right
down to the core this is terrible news
this is terrible news for the supreme
court and for america so it's no
surprise of course that the democrats
are thrilled the country is breaking
when you want to protect things in your
home from breaking you've got to check
out american home shield right now go to
ahs.com knowles i can promise you two
things i can promise you one
you will never want to fix your
household breakdowns you will not expect
them you will not want to fix them and
two they're going to happen those are
the two things i can promise you so when
they happen make sure that you are
protected with a plan from american home
shield to help cover the costs to repair
and replace things like your heating
system like your ac like your fridge
especially now that costs are going
through the roof the economy is on the
fritz make sure you are protected
they've got new options to help you find
just the right coverage if american home
shelter can't repair the covered item
they'll just replace it american home
shield members get more more coverage
options fewer exclusions you're talking
hvac systems plumbing kitchen appliances
they help protect parts of up to 23
essential home systems and appliances no
matter how old those systems and
appliances are right now you get 50
bucks off for our listeners keep your
home up and running keep your budget on
track
with american home shield right now our
listeners get 50 bucks off their most
comprehensive plans ever
ahs.com knows head over there say 50
bucks that's
ahs.com knowles for 50 off any plan
american home shield be sure with the
shield service fees limitations and
exclusions apply c plan for details
even cory booker
with his bizarre rants and his spartacus
moments and his tears of anger and wrath
even joe biden with his completely
nonsensical stammerings and his brain
made of pudding neither of them are my
least favorite democrats running the
country right now
my actual least favorite and this has
been true for two years this has been
true going back to the democrat
primaries my least favorite one
is pete buttigieg and i feel
vindicated in my distaste for pete
buddha judge because buddha judge just
went on with the cackling hands on the
view
and he was asked what he thinks about
the florida law parental rights and
education the law which says that
kindergarten teachers can't trans the
five-year-olds and pete buddha judge
said that he believes that the law
will kill
children
he's been a vocal critic of what's going
on in my state of florida when the with
the so-called don't say gay law now
which
he says will kill kids do you agree and
you know as a politician because this
this strikes you as you know your
husband is a teacher
you are
obviously lgbtq yourself and you are now
a parent yeah
so how do you feel
he's right and and i think every law to
be judged for the effect it's going to
have on real people in real life and i i
get the political reasons why they're
doing this
by the way some of those political
reasons is they don't have a plan on
anything else right i mean they they
don't have a plan on dealing with
inflation or or dealing with with gas
prices or dealing with the issues we
can't get home insurance in florida
hold on hold on i'm going to get i i'll
get to the main point that pete boudija
is making which is extremely stupid but
first i've got to get to that the second
point he says the reason they're the
reason they're preventing us from
lopping off the genitals of
five-year-olds is because they don't
have a plan on gas
you know they don't have a plan on
inflation in the economy all of that was
going great when we were running the
show dum-dum and then you guys got in
charge and all of a sudden inflation
goes through the roof and hits a 40-year
high and and gas prices also hit
all-time record highs and we know
exactly why that happened by the way if
that happened because you shut down oil
pipelines you shut down oil production
in america then you gave vladimir putin
a pipeline you okayed the pipeline that
we republicans had shut down the
pipeline which zolensky says was the
cause of the war that was the immediate
cause of the russian invasion because
biden lifted the sanctions off the oil
pipeline and now you've got a major war
in ukraine which is very important not
only to europe but to to energy
production around the world and now gas
prices are through the roof so
and now you have the audacity
to look at us and say you don't have a
plan here's my plan don't give putin a
pipeline give americans a pipeline stop
printing money like drunken sailors and
and
just do what we were doing under trump
when everything was working
that's the first part that's the i guess
that's the second stupid thing that
buddha judge said but then to his main
point
he says that the law in florida which
prevents you from
introducing five-year-olds to
transgenderism in public school
classrooms
the law in florida which stops teachers
from encouraging five-year-old kids to
take cross-sex hormones and lop off
their genitals he says that law is going
to kill kids
pete buddha judge who supports abortion
so
so abortion which literally kills kids
that does not kill kids according to p
buddha judge
letting five-year-olds keep their
genitals and not encouraging them to
take cross-sex hormones that will kill
kids
i didn't think i could like pete buddha
judge less than i already did
but i do frankly i liked him better when
he was on maternity leave do you
remember buddha judge becomes the
transportation secretary
we've got a major supply chain crisis
and everyone started criticizing buddha
judge because he was nowhere to be found
because he was on maternity leave pete
buddha judge was out i guess recovering
from his c-section maybe he was chest
feeding i'm not sure exactly what he was
doing but buddha judge was out for
months
not doing his job as a cabinet secretary
and i actually liked him better then
because then he wasn't running his mouth
he was just living life as a private
citizen which is where he should be
now he's coming out and saying we need
to trans the kids and he does it in this
way to make it sound like we're the
unreasonable ones
the vast majority of americans who
support the florida law we're the
unreasonable you know these guys it's
just for political reasons and look i
get it i get their political reasons but
we have to we have to trans the kids or
or that will kill them
and this is what they say by the way
this is you know how desperate the
democrats are on this they've got no
argument whatsoever for transiting the
kids because it's just an absolute
it's the most outrageous thing they've
done since they legalized the national
national killing of little babies in the
womb
but they've got no answer here so they
say well if you don't let us trans the
kids they're going to kill themselves
this is what this is what abusive
girlfriends and boyfriends do if you
leave me i'm going to kill myself if you
do anything i'm going to kill this is
it's the exact same tactic if you don't
let us trans the kids they're going to
kill themselves that's not true first of
all there's no evidence
there's no social scientific evidence
for the claims that they're making that
if we don't put kids if we if we don't
allow people to chop off parts of their
bodies and mutilate themselves that
they're they're going to kill themselves
the
rates of suicide depression anxiety and
all the rest of it
in post-op and pre-op transgender people
that is people who are suffering sexual
confusion are almost exactly the same
i don't really buy statistics generally
i don't really buy social science but
i'm more than happy to quote it when it
backs up my view and that's what's going
on here so even if their premise were
right
that
if rates of anxiety and depression and
suicide went down after mutilating your
body that therefore we should do it
even if that were right
it's
it it's not true in reality but but
furthermore what buddha judge is showing
here is an important issue that we've
got to confront on transgenderism
which is we can't split the baby on it
it's got to be all or nothing either
transgenderism is real and we've got to
endorse the surgeries or it's false
and it's not real and a man can't
secretly be a woman and our souls
actually do have something to do with
our bodies
and that's it because if transgenderism
is real
and if
the surgeries
can better help you to deal with your
gender dysphoria
then for sure we should do it in kids
right
if the idea is that puberty is is the
real cause of this discomfort or it
greatly accelerates the sexual
discomfort people have because
one is really a woman but then he takes
on all of these much more masculine
secondary sex characteristics then of
course you should put the kid on puberty
blockers
if if you if the kid is really a woman
and by some quirk of biology he becomes
much more of a man then of course you
should stop that
so i there's a kind of
inner logic to the left's view on
transgenderism the problem is that the
premise is false because a man can't
secretly be a woman so you got to reject
the whole thing okay and the squishes
need to need to stop trying to find some
conciliatory middle ground there's no
middle ground and the libs obviously
aren't going to stop they are now
presenting transiting the kids as though
it were the most common sense ordinary
thing and if you oppose transiting the
kids that you are some sort of horrible
bigot
or some cynic political operative rather
than what you actually are which is a
person with at least a tenuous slight
grasp on reality unlike pete buda judge
unlike the entire left they're not going
to stop they're not going to stop with
adults can consenting adults can do
whatever they want an adult can chop off
his body parts if you want they're not
going to stop it's going to go all the
way down to little kids and little
toddlers and little babies they're
already doing that stand up now people
say well are you going to die on this
hill i don't intend to die on any hill
but if you don't stand up on a hill and
fight you're going to just completely
concede the whole battle
if you haven't heard of ben's new third
thursday book club now is your chance to
sign up last month he took members
through his analysis of a tale of two
cities by charles dickens you can watch
it now at dailywire.com watch third
thursday book club it's a live
experience where you get to engage with
ben in real time ask questions and
comment on the book today we've got a
new trailer check it out
i want to tell you about my third
thursday book club this is not your
average book club these are the greatest
books in the history of western
literature
we're going to dive into the greatest
works of all time these are the books
that help form the key pillars of
western civilization and help define
america and we're gonna do it live with
thousands of you our daily wire members
i'm gonna be your personal guide i've
read every one of these books i'm gonna
draw out the important lessons and
themes from every book plus i'm gonna be
answering your questions along the way
so we actually do read the book together
you join the book club you are going to
get smarter you're going to get more
knowledgeable because this is an
investment in your most valuable asset
your mind the third thursday book club
it's going to change the way you think
this month's book is the once in future
king by t.h white sign up now for third
thursdaybookclub.com
to get ben's notes sent straight to your
inbox for the once in future king by t.h
white we'll be right back with a lot
more
you remember that abortion story down in
washington dc it's the most horrifying
news story i have ever seen in my life
probably certainly in the top three it's
that these five babies were discovered
they look like babies they don't look
like a clump of cells they look very
clearly like babies they were killed
very likely in violation of federal law
they may have been killed for partial
birth abortions the abortionist who's
doing it dr cesare santangelo has gotten
completely
led off the hook here and actually the
authorities are only looking into the
pro-lifers
the ones who exposed these heinous
crimes about his heinous crime as it
gets cries out to god for vengeance
these pro-lifers are the ones being
attacked and the dc mayor muriel bowser
has just accused lauren handy and the
other pro-lifers of tampering with fetal
remains bowser has called this extremist
anti-abortion activity just taking
photos just taking photos of the reality
of abortion
that's what's called extremist
anti-abortion activity it's so extreme
because it's so extremely effective
because abortion is completely
unsupportable if you actually see the
reality of it
so bowser has said this is extremist
anti-abortion activity and this woman is
guilty of tampering with fetal remains
and then i just have one question
so what
what's the big deal
who cares if she tampered with fetal
remains
if the if the fetal remains are just
clumps of cells
if the babies are just clumps of cells
like i could i could clip my fingernails
and someone could handle that and it's
just a clump of cells it doesn't matter
there's no moral value doesn't there i
wouldn't be committing some crime if i
clipped my fingernails just like
according to the left you're not
committing any crime if you
abort a fetus
so if there's if it's no big deal then
it's no big deal right
unless it is a big deal
and what the left wants is to have it
both ways here the left wants the babies
to be
clumps of cells for the purposes of
killing them but wants the babies the
aborted babies to be
babies for the purposes of handling them
and taking photos because that would be
a crime
desecrating a body mishandling a a dead
body that that would be the crime
but which is it
certainly if it's a crime to mishandle
the dead body then it's a then it's a
crime to make the body dead in the first
place by killing the baby
but they want to have it both ways
and they can't have it both ways
right now fortunately you've got some
republican senator james lankford in
particular leading lawmakers to call for
an investigation of this
all of these people should be in prison
the abortionists and the people
helping the abortionists the pro-lifers
should immediately be released this this
is to my mind the most important news
story in the country right now that the
name cesare santangelo should be a
household name in the united states he's
the worst serial killer in the country
right now if not ever
he's just he's the new version of kermit
gosnell that was another a butcher
absolute butcher abortionist who again
the media completely blacked out his
story
that name should be
everywhere you should call your
congressman call your senator call the
mayor of dc call the fbi demand
investigations into this guy demand that
these pro-lifers led by lauren handy be
released
they're not they're going to try to
sweep this under the rug
do not let them sweep this under the rug
this is the this is the most important
story in the country right now the left
has become so much more aggressive even
than they were on abortion i used to
tell a kind of dark joke i used to say
that the the libs pretty soon they're
going to be pushing for fourth trimester
abortions
right and this no matter how extreme the
the libs got i thought fourth trimester
okay there's no way they're actually
going to call for the killing of babies
after they've been born
and then you saw a little weakening of
that you saw partial birth abortion
first of all in the 1990s and then they
got rid of that that was made illegal
then you saw ralph northam the former
democrat governor of virginia who said
well if a baby were born after a you
know if he had lots of abnormalities you
were born after a botched abortion we
would put that baby on the table and
make that baby comfortable and then have
a conversation with the mother and see
if she wanted to kill him or not
so you're actually talking about a
fourth trimester abortion and then
lawmakers in california democrats in
california just proposed a law that
would allow
parents to kill their babies after they
were born
potentially for weeks after they were
born
when when my colleagues told me about
this bill i thought okay you've been
spending a little too much time on some
of those internet forums okay you've
been going down the conspiracy theory
rabbit holes this is completely nonsense
but you and i both know that today the
difference between a conspiracy theory
and the truth is about six to nine
months in this case it was about six to
nine minutes california assembly bill
2-2-2-3
was introduced by assemblyman buffy
wicks who's a democrat from oakland and
she in this bill
would have forbidden law enforcement
from charging any woman for any action
or inaction that affects her quote
pregnancy outcome
including miscarriage stillbirth or
abortion
or perinatal death
perinatal death refers to
not just death immediately before birth
but death
in the period after birth as well
i know
that politifact and snopes and all those
liberal propagandist hacks who work in
tandem with big tech to suppress
conservatives i know they're going to
try to give me a fact check 27
pinocchios totally false pants on fire
rating here i'm just quoting the bill
i'm just quoting the bill in plain words
and i know i know they're going to try
to redefine all of these words but
that's what they're saying they're
saying mothers can kill their kids after
they're born that is how pro-abortion
the california democrats are
now
since there has been an outcry among
conservatives they are amending this
bill so this is not going to go through
but they put it in there and it's very
difficult to understand
how you put that phrase in there
unintentionally remember last week we
talked about a bill in tennessee and the
bill in tennessee was going to
create a new carve out for marriage to
protect pastors and county clerks from
having to engage in what is called
same-sex marriage for people who believe
that actually no marriage just
necessarily involves sexual difference
supreme court justice anthony kennedy
can redefine marriage all he wants but
that doesn't actually change the
definition of marriage the definition of
marriage is the same as it's been
everywhere all around the world for all
of human history and some looney tune
liberal supreme court justice can't
change that so it gave a carve out to
protect people from violating their
conscience and from violating reality
but one of the consequences of this was
the bill was sort of sloppily written
and it seemed like it could get rid of
an age requirement to get married so the
democrats jumped on this and said the
republicans are pushing for pedophilia
and child abuse and child brides
obviously that was never the case the
people who drafted the law never thought
that was the case and then they quickly
corrected it you can see how that
accident might end up in the law oh we
were changing the statute here we forgot
to include this position this particular
line and therefore through this omission
maybe it could be confusing as to what
the age is
that's not what's going on in the
california bill they included the phrase
they said a woman cannot be prosecuted
or held responsible for perinatal death
of her kid
abortion stillbirth or perinatal death
afterward
they were intending to do this and then
there was an outcry and then it went
away for now it's going to come back and
frankly they should keep it in they
should keep it in if we're going to have
a legal abortion then you should be able
to kill your kid a week after he's born
it's the same thing
do you really believe does anyone really
believe
that a baby is
categorically different five minutes
before he's born than five minutes he's
after he after he's born
no of course not
and yet in multiple states in new york
famously in colorado and lots of other
states you can kill a baby up until the
moment of birth
forget five minutes five seconds before
birth you can kill the baby five seconds
after birth you can't did did something
change well the political circumstance
changed because no longer is the baby
inside the woman
but the baby itself didn't change
and we're talking about the morality of
killing the baby so if if the if it's
immoral to kill the baby when he's
outside of the mother's womb that that
would be a violation of that child's
rights that child that would be an
assault on that child's humanity surely
the baby would be in exactly the same
condition two seconds before he were
born at least this will give her credit
buffy wicks at least she's consistent
if you're going to have legal abortion
you might as well legalize it for weeks
and weeks after the baby is born usually
the libs are subtler though there was a
headline i have to get to it i meant to
get to it last week and we didn't have
time
there's a headline the washington post
here's the headline couple sue's
fertility clinic saying they had to
abort strangers baby
there is so much in this article this
news report is is probably the most
pregnant pun very much intended
dense
interesting news report that that i've
read in months
first of all that word had is doing a
lot of work here
couples fertility clinics saying they
had to abort the strangers baby
you never have to abort any baby
and frankly even in the case of of an
ectopic pregnancy which is the one the
one case in which a baby really could
pose a threat to the life of the mother
even then you can
treat the condition with that through
the double effect of
not
actually going through and directly
committing the abortion that's a topic
for a bioethical conversation another
day all of it to say there is no case in
which you
have to
have an abortion and certainly not in
this case the baby didn't pose any
threat to the mother and yet what
happened
well using in vitro fertilization
this couple found themselves in a
strange
predicament they they couldn't conceive
on their own they went to this in vitro
place they spent a lot of money they did
all sorts of things in different cups
and different test tubes and they
created lots and lots of little embryos
that is human beings were created by
scientists in a lab most of whom were
supposed to just be frozen forever or
killed later on have those embryos
destroyed some of them might have been
killed through abortion depending on how
the process went
and whoopsie daisy they switched the
test tubes and so this couple got
someone else's baby
and then they didn't notice it
for weeks and weeks and months and
months and months this went on
i think for
24 weeks
this went on for six months as the
six-month date was approaching
right at the end of the second trimester
they realized okay it's not my baby
we're gonna kill it
and the the point of this article is to
make people feel bad for the couple
they're murderers this couple
they killed this baby this is a little
bit personal for me because i you know i
got number two on the way child number
two is on the way
my second baby is almost exactly at the
same stage of development that this baby
was when they killed him
we're not talking about a clump of cells
we're talking about this woman was
extremely pregnant this baby was kicking
all of the time this baby was not only
showing up on sonograms as a as a baby
as very obviously just a fully you can
identify every part on the baby this
baby was kicking this baby was moving
and this
heartless couple killed the baby because
well he was someone else's baby it was
it was a stranger's baby and so it's
okay to kill a stranger's baby and how
did they end up in this predicament this
is the really hard part of this
conversation
they ended up in this predicament
because of the immoral means they used
to conceive the baby i know lots of
people use ivf the pro-life movement
doesn't talk about the problems with ivf
very much because they've got bigger
fish to fry they think and they're going
to focus only on the evil of abortion
and because a lot of people conceive
using ivf and they're very happy because
they deal with infertility and ivf seems
to offer them a way out
and and there's this good end which
comes from ivf which is you get a baby
sometimes not always actually because
ivf is far from 100 success rate
but you get a baby and so you say that's
a good end
but good ends do not justify immoral
means
and i know it's a hard saying
but a pro-life movement that endorses in
vitro fertilization and all of these
other techniques to create babies
is not really going to be a pro-life
movement one because ivf
results in abortion most of the time or
in just freezing souls little human
beings just putting them in freezers
forever
okay that's that's one big problem
it can result in abortion when these
kind of mix-ups happen
even when and this happens not
infrequently by the way you don't read
about it all the time but it happens a
fair bit
even when that doesn't happen you now
have babies born to
people who are not their parents
and and in this case the couple says
they didn't want to deal with all the
lawsuits of who's really the parent
so
you're violating a child's right to be
born of his father and mother who are
joined together in marriage often it's
used
for the purpose of intentionally
depriving a child of his mother or
father because of
single people
or same-sex couples using this process
what's wrong about it at the heart
though is not even any of these
consequences which and there are lots of
consequences of it it's that
it's just
it's simply wrong in and of itself if
we're putting technology
at the heart of human reproduction we're
making a big mistake if we're putting
people in lab coats and tinkers and
scientists and bureaucrats and some
sometimes the government at the heart of
human reproduction we're making a
ghastly dystopian horrible mistake and
you're seeing the consequences of this i
remember in the bible people suffer
infertility in the bible a lot and very
often these people especially in the old
testament take matters into their own
hands and they say okay i'm going to get
a concubine i'm going to have a wife
with my or i'm going to have a child
with my wife's maid and it never works
out it never works out and it turns out
there's actually wisdom in that old book
it's not it doesn't work well when we
say okay i'm going to commit this one
immoral act because it has such a good
end i know i know it can be difficult
that's that's why these examples are in
the bible that's why these examples
recur throughout literature that's why
they resound so strongly in our souls
but
you can't you can't cover every
consequence in your own head you can't
recreate the world using your own
unfettered reason things are going to go
awry
speaking of
subtlety speaking of
immoral means toward supposedly just
ends you remember
that there was that group of far
right-wing militiamen
who kidnapped governor gretchen whitmer
or they were planning to
the democrat governor of michigan
remember that
and they these men they were far-right
radicals that's why we got a clamp down
on conservatives and then
things got a little weird then it turned
out hold on were there some federal
agents here how did they uncover the
plot in the first place okay there were
some there were some feds who were
embedded with them and they
spied and they blew the whistle and that
well hold on wait were the feds involved
in instigating well that's kind of weird
well now we've got a verdict here
the guys are going to walk
there are two guys from the whitmer plot
who pled guilty and cooperated with the
feds they they're going to suffer some
consequences but the ones who pled not
guilty they're going to walk
the jury found that found
in some cases them not guilty and in
other cases couldn't reach a verdict and
why
because
the feds entrapped them
i'm beginning to think
that
now whenever i hear about a far
right-wing radical plot i just assume it
was instigated by the federal government
do you remember there was the justice
for january 6th rally the justice for
january 6th rally
was a rally to because unfortunately for
the federal government they couldn't
arrest enough people on january 6 the
greatest worst coup d'etat insurrection
in american history so they tried to
recreate it and when you looked at the
crowd that was there it was about ninety
percent media then eight percent feds
and then two percent some guys wandered
in from appalachia they didn't get the
memo that it was all fake there was that
that photo of these guys who had just
had a fresh haircut almost certainly at
the pentagon or at langley
they were all wearing the same logo free
clothing the same garmin watch the same
shades all checking their checking their
five checking their sevens all around
they stuck out like a sore thumb and it
was clear it was all just feds they were
all just trying to entrap everything
they said hey come on come on do a
terrorism come on right wingers come on
just do an insurrection
that's what that's what's going on here
i'm beginning to think
well i've thought this for a long time
actually that the ku klux klan
or any of whatever neo-nazi groups in
america
is just all feds and they're all just
spying on each other and maybe like one
guy who wandered in from the backwoods
didn't know he was there so this is good
this is good news
this is justice for people who were
entrapped
just as a vindication for right wingers
who were wrongly smeared by the libs and
it's just it's just another hoax
perpetrated by the deep state the russia
hoax was probably the clearest one
then there was the ukraine hoax remember
that trump had a phone call with ukraine
and they're going to impeach him over
that
and then they were they're all of these
hoaxes
january 6 we were told was the most
violent awful insurrection and the
conservatives were there clubbing
police officers over the head and
killing them all of that was fake all of
that was made up and now even the new
york times and washington post admits it
so the next time you hear one of these
stories
maybe just hang back a little maybe say
you know i'm going to wait until some
more information
comes out
speaking of crime
kim kardashian her favorite hobby other
than dating these sort of
meth-head-looking people from saturday
night live her favorite hobby is trying
to spring criminals from prison she
loves it this is
one of the things that really harmed the
trump administration is that the trump
administration which was brought to
power on really popular issues get tough
on crime get tough on the border bring
some
sense and stability back to our country
well he ended up pushing this jailbreak
bill and he did it in large part because
of the advocacy of people like kim
kardashian
who say well these poor people who are
in prison they were unfairly convicted
or even so their sentence was too harsh
even if they did the crime so kim
kardashian recently has gone
too far apparently even for her and her
handlers she's been trying to get texas
governor greg abbott to stop the
execution of a mother who brutally beat
and murdered her two-year-old daughter
so this mother her name is melissa lucio
she pled guilty to the crime
and kim kardashian said no it was a
false confession
she didn't really do it
melissa lucio's daughter mariah
was found
dead
and she had
a weeks-old broken arm the arm had been
broken for weeks but no one had treated
it she had bite marks on her body she
had patches of hair missing
and
so the mother was arrested for kill oh
and when the mother was arrested by the
way
she was asked how did the how did the
little girl die and the mother said she
fell down the stairs this is the oldest
line in the book for people who abused
their spouses and abused their families
they fell down the stairs and that's
what kim kardashian was pushing
then by the way they they did an
examination of how the girl died she
didn't die from falling down the stairs
she died from blunt force trauma
melissa lucille had 13 other kids who
were not in particularly great shape
either
and this poor little girl was killed and
now kim kardashian
begging begging
to free this woman obviously she should
not be
but kardashian's not alone here
the the real issue with the katanji
jackson confirmation is this issue
and i'm not even just talking about
child abuse because katanji had this
this weird history of letting child
rapists and and pedophiles off the hook
it's this issue of always taking the
side of the criminal to the neglect of
the victim that the criminal must always
have been done wrong by society and what
we need to do is just let them off the
hook reduce sentences let them out of
jail abolish prisons if we can defund
the police that's the problem that's
what they say
now obviously that premise is not
right
but it's a premise that totally pervades
the left it gets back to that question
tom cotton asked he said you you judge
jackson you spent your whole sentencing
here talking about how sorry you felt
for the perpetrator of the crime do you
feel any sorrow for the victim or no
you're only taking the criminal side and
it just gets to down to a fundamental
view of how we how we see the world
do you believe that that men are perfect
we're born perfect there's no original
sin and the only way we're corrupted is
by society and society how society got
corrupted that's another question and
society is so broken and these poor
criminals they're put upon they never
had a chance and we've got to we've got
to be really good to them we've got to
give them a second third fourth 75th
127th chance
or
do men have some corruption in their
hearts is this a broken world and is the
best way to deal with that corruption to
to pursue justice real justice for
victims and for the criminals by the way
to help reform their ways which is it
which is are we going to end up with
utopia if we just tweak a few more laws
or do we need to perpetually deal with
crime and pursue justice the latter is
the conservative point of view the
former is the liberal point of view it's
pushed by kim kardashian and judge
jackson and everyone in between we've
got a kardashian on the court now when
we're talking about our basic premises
of criminal justice
one one ought to pray for our country
with with that kind of point of view on
the court i'm michael nolsus the michael
nola shall see you tomorrow
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boring supervising producer mathis
glover production manager pavel vadovsky
editor and associate producer danny
d'amico associate producer justine
turley audio mixer mike coromina and
hair and makeup by cherokee heart
michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 22.
on the matte wall show we talk about the
things that matter real issues that
affect you your family our country not
just politics but culture faith current
events all the fundamentals if they
matter to you come check out the show